oh boy do we have some more tea that's
been teen spilling freakin everywhere
now Jake fall out of nowhere
nobody jake paul cody KO is a bully Jane
Paul tried to cancel the code eco and
it's some beautiful cringe that we're
gonna watch now let's enjoy good time
his face was priceless
oh my god for those of you who don't
know Cody Co isn't coming he makes fun
of other people's content for a living
and Jake Paul has a couple of things to
say to Jake Paul but no more hiding
behind the screen
face to face I assume it's gonna be
something like Oh Cody huh you know I
could beat you up man but I'm not gonna
and your bully your bully Cody I don't
like you Cody
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh I I gotta put
something on the team Orson yo did you
see his face that was priceless let's
zoom in on that face he's smiling
normally okay that's worth at least a
million Cody's magnet we go and we're
about to like freak his life up is the
general exception but I can't really
fault him for not speaking perfectly
thanks mom
kind of not really I'm not a good friend
to like one of my biggest haters
twenty-eight-year-old wanna be a
comedian kotico I saw this 28 I'm 29 oh
no the first time when he was working at
full screen which is like a YouTube
community network adds like a little am
i watching this is two times and I
didn't even realize sorry okay and now
he just on people to become famous
that's that's that's it
I'm not YouTube's here oh I'm not here
to like save the day and and like you
know do you do like all this no
no one is thinking that Jake don't
worry-you me to specify yeah but this
guy code Eco is a bully he's a cyber
bully and I hate I mean hate cyber
bullies like I hate it it's the worst
thing in the world people
wasn't there a bunch of allegations that
Jake polled was a bully in school that
was never really addressed all right so
what's the problem with Cody code then
what did he do hiding behind their
computers talking [ __ ] about other
people it's consumed our generation it's
consumed our society and I think it's
largely in part to do with these
negative trolls online whether 2.5
million subscribers all the way to
people like keemstar who have even more
subscribers than that that just spread
negativity into the earth I [ __ ] hate
it I don't under you just swear the Jake
pulled your sweater
Jake Paul made us more dead Paul made us
more take Paul made us more what the
Frick man now I wash code eCos content
and it's generally just poking fun or
cringing at what other people create I
don't really see him going looser and
looking stupid face like and I want to
like put a voice up against it not to
maybe start a conversation about how we
can stop it and maybe not support these
types of people who are literally
causing the youth to be like negative
and have like a lot of animal
I like that Jake Paul out of all people
is criticizing how other people are
influencing the youth I think that's
he's definitely the right person could
do that thank you Jake called what could
we possibly do without you the reason I
feel like I can like touch on this
subject and it'd be completely fairs
because kotico has made probably like 10
videos now and dozens of tweets talking
[ __ ] about not only me but my brother we
criticized his song he said he doesn't
like logan paul dan he's got 64 thousand
retweets
that's the one that got in the back well
who's that one love you all things for
this boy can't wait to continue you got
fired
oh that's funny I don't mean me but my
brother and there's some of his like
most viewed videos like I said I don't
like making these videos and like to me
it's kind of like I just [ __ ] just
like doing [ __ ] just to like talk can
you stop swearing
what the Frick [ __ ] about each other but
no that's the sense are the first one
who's editing your videos Jake
god damn actually the case and where
this video is going is I am I'm going to
confront kotico in person today the
backstory of this is my friend Jeff yeah
has like a podcast dad YouTube kind of
show where he interviews guests and cody
KO is going on to his barbershop guest
podcast thingy
today and jeff called me and was like yo
I know you and Cody Koda have had beef
in the past I thought it'd be funny if
you came out and you confronted Cody in
person and got his reaction on camera
sounds like your friend yeah got you
baited sense sounded like Jeff just
wanted more attention and he knew you'd
fall for it god dammit Jake so I think
you know if I was Jake poles and I was
gonna do this then I would bring up some
examples of why this code eco guy is
such a threat or why he said it's so bad
spoilers he doesn't it actually makes it
his jokes ten times funnier because Jake
Paul is putting them up there be like
how could he say this so he's just
deciding all of a sudden that it's time
to [ __ ] on somebody if you don't know
it's been bass he's dubbed them
Jake Pollard's creative he came out with
a song a new song they both come out
with songs actually Logan's I watched
that one he's dressed up as a minion
who made that call who signed off on
that who was like yet dude for your
first single ever for the video you
should definitely dress up as the thing
that everybody in America hates most
I can't imagine like being a human and
having this much hatred inside like he
says commenting why did he dress up like
a mess and Jake Paul is treating it like
he just gave away his address to someone
oh wait you did that Jake oh no sorry
minion made that call who signed off on
that who was like yeah dude freaking how
could if Logan Paul wants to dress up as
a minion then let him do it god damn it
to the center we can have so much hate
for minions why do people hate minions I
don't get it your first single could you
not have bring up brought up any better
examples I can feel like there's
probably some discussion worth having
here about channels that are literally
only dedicated to other people for Jake
Paul to make this video everybody in
America hates most
and I know for a fact that Cody makes
his own original content as well it's
not like he only makes those videos I
can't imagine like being a human and
having this much hatred inside like you
f sociopath confirmed Jake Paul wrecked
our confirmed belittle somebody so much
that like you're just [ __ ] on every
little possible detail that this person
is really explain what Jake Paul came
brain is trying to say here they are
channels that are dedicated purely to
criticize people and these channels
clearly have to make a living giving
their audience what they want so they to
nitpick a lot of things that aren't that
big of a deal and I've seen this many
times of these channels they they
nitpick these small things that doesn't
matter but since there are they built an
audience around this topic of just
people
then they all get along with us well
like yeah how dare that person sell
slightly over priced merch we need to
cancel them and it just creates this
toxic atmosphere and I get that but for
Jake Paul to make this video is
beautiful it's so funny watching this
with this he added this eerie music in
the Edit for the Frick likes minions my
mom
Jake Paul treats it like this is the
worst thing anyone's ever said about him
I haven't checked it out yet honestly
I've been waiting honestly i a sec I
like I think I hate he's terrible like
this videos are terrible I don't I don't
even want to watch him oh my god
honestly can't even continue watching
him make fun of minions anymore I will
not stand for this I will rise up and
beyond the point is here are some
examples of like the people II [ __ ] on
the Joe she's made about people it's
just not acceptable this is Logan Paul
with better hair I make this so much
funny and then Jake Paul Nick picked
these what kinda M night Shyamalan
ending was that absolute classic
starting situation right there folks you
know when you're juggling your soccer
ball alone you got a blonde oh Jesus
Christ
you know this is not comedy you can do
this with anything I'm not really sure
if that's the right thing and he's like
come on just do it it's not a big deal
who do you want to date I'll have my
father's videos right
oh dude you're drinking comm powder how
dare you hey joke it's just too far all
of hatred that has a fan base that can
that can affect the world like I said I
don't want to be like aha the youtubes
hero right now it's affecting the world
but I do want to see how well he will
react when he's confronted in person
this guy is 28 years old like sitting
behind the computer making fun of like
kids that are younger than him and he's
he's comedic like yes some of this stuff
is funny like it's funny to make jokes
about people and like
that's okay but there's definitely he's
definitely crossing the line in in a
huge way where if someone was watching
this video and it was a gives some
examples of that was you brought up are
not crossing the line no one thinks that
way at least but think about like what
that is actually doing to these people
that you're laughing at or that he's
like making fun of and I can only
imagine what he is going through as a
person you know like like how how hurt
he feels on the inside to where he needs
like drag people down to to make himself
feel better to like push his career
farther down the line can only imagine
just how much suffering kotico has to
deal with every day for being such a
savage online he must be carrying so
much like maybe every wheels like you
need to hate on other people you find
your self hating on other people accept
that and maybe figure out how you can
not do that more advice from Jay Paul
everyone just accept it and figure out
how to not do it if you got hate in your
heart just accept it and figure out how
to remove it you're gonna spin Cody
around I'm gonna go into this closet
that's on the set I'm gonna be hiding in
that closet and then Jeff is going to
ask Cody a question about me and I am
going to come out soon after after that
I don't I really truly feel like this is
not Jake Poulos idea I think someone is
feeding him these ideas I'm like all
these people they're just bullies Oh
like I don't know how he comes to this
conclusion at least it doesn't make
sense to me
[Music]
I don't wanna fight
God McRib all these kids bro kids which
kids
I don't like cyber bullies in here so
it's a pretty relevant question I like
how Cody just put him on the spot right
away what kids I don't like it you cyber
boy kids may I don't like it I don't
like like there's kids out there like
girls who you like into like going in on
don't don't worry you already shown them
in the video Jake I'm not really sure if
that's the right thing and he's like
come on just do it it's not a big deal
who the frill like there's kids out
there like I've met girls who you like
into it like gone in on like I don't
need to bring up their names to cause
drama for them you know what I'm saying
but like but like that [ __ ] that you do
like you sit in front of camera like
actually like can resonate into people's
hearts like that's not cool I was don't
like me
be there bro maverick I'm gonna show
soon everypony to the party yeah you
said sorry bro I'll shake your hand I
was a it's like the most insincere
apology I've ever heard sorry for
bullying you I guess Rico can't come to
his party this is so sad Oh was that set
up I feel like that was set up like hey
oh yeah that was set up yeah you said
sorry bro I'll shake your hand for that
no just say no okay oh my god oh I gotta
sit down for this once forgot to cut it
out oh yes oh I'm so glad I noticed that
just say no just see the line where you
say no we can't come to the party Jake
it was even like oh yeah you can come he
said sorry oh my god this is beautiful
I'm so happy he missed a handshake
that's super embarrassing how could
anyone do that I've never done that what
jokes what jokes did he make about him
cody's and i don't want to be here mode
I'm just gonna check my phone I was
being nice now Cody makes tasteful
videos he likes to hold the phone at
people that I mean okay yes like some of
it's funny right like you have clearly
have a huge audience where you're
spreading so much negativity so it's
like where's Fineman where's the where's
the where's the where's the bear like
worked where's like the where do you
stop where's the line you know where is
your like funny versus like that's
stuffing like you're you're spreading
like a lot of [ __ ] on the internet of
fast
different lines yeah exactly they're
completely subjective what you're saying
for sure like like I told him if he made
a video about me I'd be crushed but then
at the same time I told you man I keep
it fun I keep it light-hearted no yeah
well can we have some examples where you
don't then that isn't just random clips
that are completely incomprehensible I
give Cody Co goes above beyond the line
then at least show that I'm not
defensive I just
my doctor fine you're hilarious you're
so funny
got'em also Jake Paul wannabe comedian
you're hilarious
stop swearing Jake
I'm on one side of the spectrum and he's
on one out of the other side of the
spectrum you know but there should be
like a middle ground we're like we can
actually make a difference you didn't
really seem like he was trying to budge
like you were you were pretty
understanding you know and you were
trying to like find like a new
perspective and I don't think he was
really open to that kind of deflecting
the whole time we're back now and
watching this watching this footage back
over then Jake Paul reviews the footage
where he got him yeah so homey
immediately like tries to you know he
smiles like you know he's definitely
obviously nervous he goes to yours just
shake my hand because he's probably so
caught off guard what you do have is a
talent Cody and I challenge you bro to
take that talent of like being funny and
put it elsewhere into something positive
that like they say oh look at his face
look how nervous he doesn't look nervous
I don't know I don't care what he's
saying if anything Jay came across as
more than others which kids like he's
that he's deflecting like no it's a
pretty reasonable question even like he
doesn't even want to like what kids with
like kids which kids like bro how about
the 200 videos that you have on your
YouTube channel I'm sorry man looks down
at the ground and like is like I'm sorry
man like he didn't even look down he's
like I'm sorry man I'm sorry man
looks down at the ground and like is I'm
sorry man like these are the types of
like these are the types of like they're
not like he's not like a real man he's
28 years old and he's like ah I'm sorry
man like sorry for talking [ __ ] about
you for 45 minutes
take your doing where you're criticizing
him for doing you understand that right
he's not a real man wannabe comedian
nitpicking things from a scenario I get
it you want to give him the taste of
your own medicine but I don't know man
I challenge you Jake Paul to remove any
hate from your heart
as awful as his video is Jake Paul
somewhere in there there is a point to
be made I feel like and he didn't say
this to start a conversation I don't
think he necessarily did this video to
end at all I think it was done extremely
poorly it was a bad subject to pick as
well it reminded me a little bit about I
don't know if you guys saw him where
Shane Dawson confronted his biggest
hater and then as soon as they met it
was like oh yeah we're best friends now
yeah we love each other yeah and it's
just like cringe dude if you have your
opinion at least stand by it and it
seems like Cody at least did that so
Jake paulie's obviously figured that a
lot of people criticizes I can't imagine
Jake Paul really going against that and
being like you know what this guy sucks
too I guess he did that in this video
it's like the only role that he
physically cannot fill so obviously he's
gonna take the moral high ground on it
If Jake Paul's point is that oh you need
to be publicly humiliated to learn then
why are you still the same Jake that was
a joke anyway I think there are channels
that are bad in that regard of just
focusing on nitpicking topics about
people a lot of them also are good in
the sense that since they're dedicated
on these topics a lot of times they get
a lot of topics really well and really
right and really quickly so I think
they're important as well anyway that's
it bye what you never play too /
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]